I want to tell you about exotic objects
in topology
before I do that let me just tell you
more generally what topologists do we
study geometric shapes but unlike in
ordinary geometry we don't care about
lengths angles areas volumes we don't
care about any of that we just care
about what properties geometric shapes
have that are unchanged when you deform
them and by deform I mean you're allowed
to bend it and twist it and stretch it
as if it's made of an elastic material
but you're not allowed to break it so a
square for example if we started
manipulating that it would very quickly
not be a square anymore that's right we
have a square right here and I could
turn it into a circle or more or less a
circle by just bending it and I could
also turn it into a triangle but what I
cannot do is turn let's say a circle
into two circles the only way to do this
would be to break it and then glue it
back but that's not allowed similarly I
could have a ball
and I could turn it into a cube there's
a saying that topologists are people who
cannot tell apart Donuts from coffee
mugs so for example here is a donut
and here is a coffee mug
I mean they're the same they're the same
for us because you could deform one into
the other they both have this hole
through them but what I cannot do is
turn the donut into a bowl because the
ball doesn't have a hole so I don't want
to punch a hole in it that's not allowed
and well I could do that by taking a
bite out of the donut but with apologies
are healthy people we're not supposed to
be eating Donuts the objects that we
mostly care about are called manifolds
these are objects that look from any
given point they look pretty much like
flat space or n-dimensional hyperspace
what is n-dimensional hyperspace in
dimension one we have a line in
dimension two we have the plane in
dimension three we have space and then
you can think about Dimension four just
add another variable say time and that's
four dimensional hyperspace and you can
just add more variables five dimensional
and six dimensional and so on WE it's
not something that we can visual lies
but we can think of it mathematically
anyway and we can write down equations
and manifolds see in this space
or are manifolds the space themselves
they can stay they can sit in the space
but they could also look like that space
around any point so let me tell you an
example the surface of the Earth is a
great example it's a sphere more or less
it's called a geoid it has mountains and
valleys but remember we can all deform
them and make it into a sphere
topologically it's a sphere and it sits
in three-dimensional space but around
any point it looks like two-dimensional
plane because I can move in basically
two directions I can move left and right
and forwards and backwards there are two
degrees of freedom so that's what I'm
saying that the sphere is a
two-dimensional manifold even though it
lives in three-dimensional space okay
other examples of two-dimensional
manifolds would be the surface of the
donut or this famous client bottle yes
if I live on it again I wouldn't be able
to tell the difference from from a plane
just like it's very hard to tell the
difference between a plane and the the
Earth the sphere from where we are to
really tell them apart you would have to
go far away and see that you come back
there are also one-dimensional manifolds
like this circle right here it's a
one-dimensional manifold if we only
lived on this on the circle then we
would only have one direction in which
to move in and then there are three
dimensional manifolds like our ordinary
space or the universe around every point
it looks like we have three dimensions
to go into we also have the bottom and
top
uh but we actually don't know the shape
of the universe it's a three-dimensional
manifold it could be hyperspace but it
could be what's called a
three-dimensional hypersphere perhaps if
we go very high up then we would come
back to where we are nobody has done
that but we don't know if it's possible
or not just like on the surface of the
Earth when you go around you come back
so we just know it's a three-dimensional
manifold is there no way to test for
that it seems strange that we could not
know that even the one we're living in
the one we're living and breathing in
that is the only way to test to walk
forever and see if I can no there are
other ways people are looking at Cosmic
microwave background radiation and they
they have put forward various theories
about what the shape of the universe is
but there is no definite theory that
everyone accepts that it's not yet known
what shape it is but there are some
hints from the universe okay so we have
three dimensional objects and then we
can think about four dimensionals and so
on a good example is this hypersphere so
in dimension one we have the circle
which is a one-dimensional manifold and
it's the set of points at the given
distance from the origin it's given by
the equation x squared plus y squared
equals one similarly we have the sphere
which is again the set of points at
distance one from a given point but it
lives in three-dimensional space and
it's given by the equation x squared
plus y squared plus Z squared equals one
and we can generalize this we can talk
about the N dimensional hypersphere
which is given by the equation X1
squared plus dot dot plus X N squared
plus another variable x n plus 1 squared
equals one it lives in N plus one
dimensional space and it's an
n-dimensional manifold
now I'm getting to the Crux of the
matter the Exotic objects what are
exotic objects
these are things that are topologically
the same but are smoothly different
so there are two ways of thinking about
the formations in topology I showed you
before that a circle can be turned into
a square
and in the process of course you have to
make a corner now the circle is smooth
and you can turn it into other smooth
curves like maybe something like an
ellipse and the process would be smooth
now could it be that we have two smooth
objects and you can deform one into the
other but the only way to do so is by
making Corners somewhere in the middle
then those objects would be
topologically the same but smoothly
different and I don't know if you're
more familiar with one of the objects
you would say that the second one is an
exotic copy of the other one it's like
if you live on the first object and you
go to the second one it's like going to
an exotic vacation some things are the
same but some things are just different
now how can this be how can you have two
smooth things but to deform one into the
other you need to make Corners here is
an example
we have a figure eight and can I turn it
into a circle well I can I can do so if
I make one of the loops smaller and
smaller
but at some point I have to make a
corner and then it becomes a circle
now that's not actually a good example
because if I had a third dimension if I
allow myself to just lift this up then
it would become a circle just smoothly
so this is not a real example of exotic
objects in fact I cannot show you exotic
objects because they don't exist in
Dimensions one two and three in the
dimensions that we can easily visualize
they only start existing in dimension
four and higher the first examples were
found in 1956 by a mathematician called
John Milner and they were found in
dimension seven they are exotic
hyperspheres of seven dimensions so
there is some object an exotic sphere
that you can deform into the ordinary
seven-dimensional sphere but not
smoothly an exotic sphere is a smooth
object that I can deform into a sphere
but I cannot deform it smoothly I would
have to make Corners in the middle let
me show you now the numbers of spheres
in each dimension in dimension 1 2 3
there's just one the standard one the
same goes in Dimensions five and six now
in dimension seven we actually have 28
spheres so there's the standard one and
then there are 27 different ones then we
have two spheres in dimension eight then
eight then six then in dimension eleven
we have 992 spheres in dimension 12 we
have just one then three feed and 216
and 256 and so on if you look at the
sequence of numbers it looks strange I
grant you that but there are some
patterns for example in Dimensions 7 11
15 every four dimensions you have you
get a lot more exotic spheres than in
the other nearby Dimensions one thing
you can ask is in what dimensions do
Exotic spheres exist and in what
dimensions does just the standard one
we see that there's just one sphere in
Dimensions one two three five six twelve
and also mathematicians figure out the
same as the two in Dimensions 56 and 61.
so does that mean if I was an object
living in a 61-dimensional universe it's
a little bit more boring than some of
the other ones that's right yes these
are the boring Dimensions you don't have
exotic spheres although you do have some
other exotic objects in these Dimensions
just not spheres these numbers seem so
arbitrary I assume it's impossible for
someone to easily explain why it's
certain numbers that are boring and
other ones that are hyper exotic these
numbers are hard to compute does the
whole story involving Bernoulli numbers
and homotopic groups of spheres
the most interesting thing about them is
that we can compute them in any
Dimension except in dimension four
that's where I left a question mark
That's the biggest mystery it's one of
the most famous open problems in
topology it's called the
four-dimensional smooth Point correct
conjecture which says that there are no
exotic spheres in dimension four but we
don't know that for sure yet we don't
know there are examples of objects that
are smooth and you can deform them into
the ordinary four-dimensional sphere by
introducing corners but people don't
know if you can do that smoothly or not
I have also looked for exotic
four-dimensional sphere myself and I
couldn't find any if you did would you
become a very famous mathematician
absolutely yeah is that is it what it's
not like a millennium problem is or
anything or is it no there was a similar
conjecture in dimension three the point
correct conjecture that was the one
problem in topology among the my
Millennium Problems that was solved by
Pearlman in 2003 and I think now the
most famous remaining open problem in
topology is this one about Dimension
four but it hasn't yet made it to the
list of Millennium Problems Professor
don't waste your time making number five
videos you need to go upstairs and solve
this problem
number file videos are important too
[Laughter]
so why is dimension 4 so difficult
good question
well it's more difficult than the lower
Dimensions one two three becomes in
those Dimensions we can see things and
there are also geometric techniques that
mathematicians use to study shapes in
these Dimensions what's interesting is
that it's also simpler than Dimensions
five six and greater and the reason for
that is a trick about separating disks
to explain it let me say one way in
which topologists distinguish between
shapes if I have
a lasso and I throw it somewhere on the
plane or even on the surface of the
Earth which is a sphere it would
surround a region so I could just
contract it into a blob around a little
point but if I have the same lasso and I
would put it around the surface around a
hole in a donut then I wouldn't be able
to contract it without breaking the
donut and that's one way you can tell
the donut apart from the sphere
so to study these objects mathematicians
are looking at loops and how you
contract them and the contraction spans
a disc a disc is a two-dimensional
object and it's easier to study these
objects if you can split apart the disks
so that you can study each complication
one at a time all right how can you
split apart disks well let me start with
lines if I have two lines and they're on
the plane and they intersect if I move
one a little bit I'm not going to be
able to take it off the other but I can
take it off if I allow myself to go into
space the reason is that 3 is greater
than one plus one
each line is a one-dimensional object
and one plus one is two but I have one
extra Dimension and that's why I can do
it similarly if I'm interested in
separating disks each disk is a
two-dimensional object and two plus two
is four so I need one extra Dimension so
in Dimensions five and higher I can
separate disks and that just makes
topological objects easier to study this
is called the Whitney trick and it led
to the classification of smooth
manifolds in higher dimensions
back in the 60s and this is the problem
with Dimension four you can't in
dimension four you haven't got the space
what to to break to separate two discs
that's right we don't have the geometric
methods from lower dimensions and we
don't have this trick about separating
disks and that makes dimension for the
hardest to wrap our heads around
to give you an example of something
that's unique to Dimension four instead
of looking at exotic spheres let's look
at the Exotic hyperspaces remember we
had the line and then the plane and then
the space and in N Dimensions we have
the hyperspace
so could you have an exotic hyperspace
something that looks like like a plane
or a space and you can deform it into
the ordinary one but only by making
corners
here are the numbers of hyperspaces in
each dimension in any Dimension except
for there is just one there's just a
standard one and there are no exotic
hyperspaces but in dimension four we
have infinitely many in fact it's more
than infinitely many it's uncountably
many it's not the kind of infinity that
you can count one two three and so on
it's as many exotic hyperspaces as there
are real numbers
and this doesn't happen in any other
dimensions if you have exotic objects in
some other dimensions you know that
there are always finitely many of them
there's finitely many exotic spheres as
I showed you that list of numbers but in
dimension four you can have infinitely
many exotic objects and yeah that's what
makes Dimension 4 so fascinating does
this mean to mention four is something
that you should be spending more time on
because it's so special or is this a
sign that maybe this is a bit of an
aberration that you should leave alone
it's a place where you shouldn't play
that depends on your perspective there
are mathematicians who work on the other
dimensions and there are mathematicians
that work on Dimension four I'm in the
latter category because quite often when
I speak to number theorists and I talk
to me about prime numbers and they're
showing me some interesting property of
prime numbers they very often discard
too they say we're not going to use two
because that's an aberration and it
ruins everything it ruins all our laws
and principles and that and they just
throw it aside it sounds like the fourth
dimension is your equivalent that's
pretty much it in many theorems you say
this is happening in all Dimensions
except for and we understand what's
happening and we just don't know what's
happening in dimension four but I find
that interesting and worthy of study
foreign
[Music]
[Music]